hey everyone it's Mike from motor flows
and welcome back to my channel you know
in today's video I'm going to go over a
question that was left in the comments
uh by a user uh Amo said are passive
orders the stop-loss orders of
aggressive buyer or aggressive sellers
um no they're not and and what this
video is I'm going to go into the
difference between um passive orders and
aggressive orders and their significance
um this is uh you know a a topic that is
related because you know by
understanding the difference between the
passive orders and the aggressive orders
you know it leads into you know one of
the important parts of order flow which
is imbalances all right so you know
before I jump in um you know be sure to
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already and click that notification Bell
so you're notified when I post a new
video and again you know this video is a
result of a user uh comment so I do uh I
do go through the comments every so
often and you know if I find one I think
that is interesting that I get asked uh
you know sort of repeatedly then I I may
make a video about it all right so I'm
all um passive orders are not the
stop-loss orders of aggressive buyers or
aggressive sellers now um there's a
couple things okay to keep in mind well
you know on a footprint right what you
have is the volume that trades on the
bid at a price level the volume trades
on the offer at a price level
now what you have to think about as well
with orderflow right when you're looking
at a footprint chart is it's the result
of what's coming through what's being
traded on the bid and the offer okay so
this is your depth of market right just
a simple one from Ninja Trader and as
you can see here this Market when it
closed on Friday I'm recording this on
Saturday the Market's not open right now
it went out 6131 and a half bid offered
at 6132 and a qu offer there was 12 on
the bid 11 on the offer this is when the
market closed but you know during the
day obviously it's going up and down
right price is being traded on the offer
price is being being traded on the bid
as opposed to on a footprint chart
you're seeing what actually traded so
what you're seeing here on this depth of
Market the price ladder is the best bids
below the current bid and the best
offers above the current offer all right
but what you're looking at on the
footprint is what's actually traded all
right
so what you have is a bid and the offer
so people that are sitting on the
bid okay are trying to buy it at a
specific price price people that are
sitting on the offer are passive
sellers right they're trying to sell it
at a at a specific price
so let's take a look here I made some
notes so passive orders are going to be
limit orders
either bids or offers right it doesn't
have to be the best bid or the best
offer it could be something sitting in
the book right it could be below the
market or above the market now
aggressive orders are basically Market
orders which you know can be triggered
stops I mean there's different types of
orders I mean if you're trading you know
that you could enter on a limit you know
you could enter on a stop you could
enter at the
market and when you have a stop order
gets triggered it becomes a market order
okay so passive orders aggressive orders
there's two types of orders I mean
there's there's sub categories there but
basically the main two types are passive
orders and limit or sorry passive orders
and aggressive orders however there's
going to be four types of Traders you're
going to have passive buyers passive
sellers aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers right because remember passive
orders aggressive orders you break that
down into between buyers and sellers so
you're going to have passive buyers
passive sellers aggressive buyers
aggressive sellers so passive buyers
they buy from aggressive
sellers passive sellers sell to
aggressive buyers and the easiest way to
think about it
is okay so if you're a passive
seller you're going to be trying to sell
it on the offer or above right you're
waiting for the market to come to you if
you're going to be aggressive if you're
an aggressive seller oh I got to I got
to get out of this position right now
right you're going to be aggressive
you're going to cross the bid offer
line and sell to who a passive buyer
somebody that's a passive buyer working
a limit order to buy okay
now aive aggressive buyers buy from whom
they buy
from passive sellers okay so all this
all this limit up here all this
liquidity this is passive orders passive
sellers okay all this buying liquidity
here right on the bid and below are
passive
buyers so aggressive sellers sell to
passive buyers right people are trying
to buy it at a specific price aggressive
buyers buy from passive sell people who
are trying to sell it at a specific
price and when you look at the footprint
right you're going to see areas where
there is imbalances right like right
here on this red candle four against 34
right this is a buying imbalance here so
in this 2-way auction between 6131 A5
and
6132 there's only four aggressive
sellers going into the bid at 61 31 A5
right
versus uh 34 aggressive buyers buying it
at
6132 so these aggressive buyers the
people that bought it aggressively here
at 32 who did they buy it from they
bought it from passive sellers just as
who did the aggressive sellers sell four
contracts to they sold it to the passive
buyers okay so if it's a limit on the
bid side it's basically a passive buyer
if it's a limit on the offer side it's a
passive
seller so let's talk a little bit
about the differences right so passive
orders like I said are limit orders
they're resting in the order book limit
orders are placed at specific levels and
wait to be filled right they might not
get filled right if if you're that's the
one of the the things if you are if the
market is 31 and a half at 32 in the
quarter and you're trying to buy it at
30 right you're on the bid down here you
might not get filled you might not even
get filled if you're on the bid at 61 31
A2 as it's currently 31 A2 at 32 it
could just start trading up and you
never get filled okay with the market
order you are crossing that bid offer
you want to get filled and you're going
to buy or sell at the best bid
or if you're buying at the best offer so
a limit
order is an order at a specific price
Traders specify the exact price at which
they're willing to buy or sell and like
I just said there's no guarantee of
execution the order may not be filled if
the market price doesn't reach the
specific specified
level limit orders provide liquidity in
the market right they add depth to the
market by either offering to buy at a
certain price or they're offering to
sell at a certain price they are
providing that liquidity this is
liquidity in the market here people come
in and offer it out they provide the
liquidity it's the people that remove
the
liquidity who are the aggressive Traders
so the diff the difference between
aggressive orders right which are Market
orders and and stops that become Market
or when say you have a stop order okay
say um you know say you sold it here at
31 and a and a half right you put a buy
stop in here at
34 to protect yourself if the market
trades up to
34 it triggers to a market order so you
your buy stop at 34 once it trades 34
the the uh program at the exchange knows
that okay that's a market that's a stop
order it traded there and it becomes a
market order to buy at the market and
it'll buy it most likely at 34 and a
quarter right unless there's a lot of
orders there and it jumps up maybe you
get a tick or two of slippage and you
pay 34 a half okay so aggressive orders
provide immediate execution they're
filled as quickly as possible at the
best available price now just bear in
mind though you know like I said they
they're filled as quickly as possible
but even within Market orders there is
still a q system right you don't really
think about it but when you
see like uh for
example here right where you see 00001
on the price or sorry on the volume at
these prices right you see buying and
balance buying and balance buying and
balance buying and balance coming up
well there might have been a stop here
at 32 that got triggered to buy you know
100 or or say 250 contracts that's why
you have you know 80 116 there there
there these
imbalances is because that first order
first stop order in the queue is being
executed and if there's another one that
came in behind it first the the
order that was in there before that you
know that the 250 Lots would be the
first one that's executed your two lot
to buy at the same price since it went
in after that other 250 lot your order
will be
executed as soon as that first order the
the order right in front the 250 Lots so
just bear that in mind right it's not
like you're all competing for the same
thing it's all being released at the
same time there even within stops there
is um a queue just as you know in limit
orders there there is a
queue now you have price uncertainty the
exact execution price may vary slightly
from the price at the time of order
placement or say order placement but
rather order well order placement or if
in the case of a stop triggered right
because you know if you've ever used a
ninja Trader or any other platform and
you enter a stop order or sorry a market
order right you think okay I'm going to
just buy at the market right and it's 32
and a quarter offer next thing you know
you're filled that two and three
quarters right because there's a lot of
trading going on really even from the
time you click submit to the time that
the order hits the exchange where the
current bid offer is right I mean you
know the markets move fast okay so just
bear that in mind then
obviously that is called slippage right
we all understand what the concept of
slippage is that's what slippage is you
know in the old days you know people
nowadays We complain about oh you know I
was
filled you know Markus two and a quarter
offered I'm filled at two and 3/4 you
know in the old days of open outcry pit
trading you know sometimes you wouldn't
even get your fill back for a day you
know especially in in mail confirmations
um it could be a couple days but you
know you place you call your broker
you'd call down you know if your broker
had floor access the broker would call
down to the floor and hopefully if the
order is big enough they can hand signal
it in otherwise um you know they would
run it in you so you got to wait for the
runner to you know you got wait for the
phone clerk to take the order fold the
paper run it to the pit if it's Market
order
you know hopefully the broker would fill
it instantly and get it back otherwise
you know he'll just sort of he'd fill it
stick it in his pocket and he sort of
got to wait a little bit and then uh you
so you could be waiting a while and the
price that you saw on the screen when
you place the order be very different
than your execution price on a market
order but we live in uh better days now
in the sense of uh trans not
transparency but uh order execution so
liquidity removal
right Market orders which are aggressive
orders consume existing orders in the
order book right which helps
to um move price but they are basically
removing liquidity from the market right
imagine right if someone give you an
idea what I'm talking about right
someone provides liquidity okay I'll
offer 11 at 32 and a qu well someone
buys the 11
they've just removed that
liquidity okay so that that's you know
sometimes you hear the term um liquidity
providers that's what a liquidity
provider does right that's what a market
maker does he provides bids and offers
it's the uh people that are being
aggressive and removing the liquidity
from the market and urgency aggressive
order so strong buying or selling
pressure right I I explained the whole
concept of imbalances in the market
okay and imbalances obviously are going
to be caused by aggressive Traders right
and
um getting to one step further with uh
Delta right is the net difference
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers in a bar so if a bar right like
this red big red candle's got negative
Delta of minus
179 it's that's not the volume the
volume's in this bar 3,800 but what the
1,00 79 is is the difference between net
aggressive selling and net aggressive
buying in a
bar okay and there's ways to use Delta
um I've created a lot of videos on on
ways to interpret
Delta just as here you have this bar has
got positive Delta
1625 right so again that's not the
volume for the bar that's telling you
that there was
1,625 more aggressive buyers than
aggressive sellers in a bar okay and
Delta is it's a useful tool for
orderflow Traders because it's it's data
from the market okay and you know data
is depending on on how you use it it can
be
uh can be a gold mine so all right
anyone so I hope that uh helps uho with
your question again you know thanks for
uh putting your question out there there
there's a question I'm going to get to
hopefully this uh this weekend on
covering trading view
versus ninja Trader Footprints right cuz
trading view does have a footprint but
there are some things you do need to
know about using the trading view
footprint that
uh you have to be aware of okay so
thanks I'll catch you guys on that next
video take care bye-bye